mariupol una vez una próspera ciudad
portuaria de 430 mil habitantes está
siendo reducida a escombros por la
artillería rusa el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski afirma que unos
100.000 civiles siguen atrapados allí en
condiciones inhumanas pues y riesgo sin
comida ni agua ni medicinas bajo los
constantes ataques y bombardeos llevamos
más de una semana intentando organizar
corredores humanitarios estables para
los residentes de mariupol casi todos
nuestros intentos por desgracia se ven
frustrados por los ocupantes rusos
ocupante mente miles de personas han
sido evacuadas de esta semana aunque se
les que afirma que incluso los propios
convoyes humanitarios han sido tomados
como prisioneros por las fuerzas rusas
la caída de mariupol abriría un enlace
terrestre entre la península de crimea
anteriormente anexionada y las zonas
separatistas prorrusas de doñetsk
lugansk más al este también es un enlace
crucial para el comercio marítimo de
ucrania lo que la convierte en un
objetivo clave para la invasión rusa
kray en todo ucrania hemos tenido unos
200 casos de ataques a ellos dos años y
la mitad de ellos es a mariupol así que
cada 15 minutos utilizar una bomba en
mar y polvo mariupol la negativa de los
ucranianos a rendirse ha provocado que
los ataques rusos sean cada vez más
indiscriminados contra las
infraestructuras y los civiles incluida
la destrucción de un teatro en el que se
refugiaban más de 1.000 residentes y de
una escuela de arte en las que unas 400
personas habían buscado protección el
recuento de víctimas de los ataques
sigue siendo imposible de establecer
debido a los intensos combates
callejeros que se están produciendo en
la zona naciones unidas calcula que hay
20.000 víctimas civiles en mariupol y
unos 3.000 muertos pero la cifra real
sigue siendo desconocida